das ist heftig war der käse schmeckt
echt geil du hast so amerikanisch mit
ulrich weiß richtig lecker stellst dich
oder mach ich es gut gemacht
[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute achtung
einen baklava cheesecake ich hatte vor
jahren mal einen kaffee es klick gemacht
wenn carl davis es so dass sie dieses
engelshaar diese kleinen teich fäden die
man auch in der orientalischen küche
führt zum beispiel kühler für benutzt
oder diese ganzen süßen sachen und heute
nehme ich aber viel teig also baklava
tag total unkompliziert also macht sich
überhaupt keine sorgen wenn den bug
empfänger so klickt ihr das safe hin ich
starte jetzt wie bei so vielen
orientalischen rezepten erstmal mit dem
zucker sirup alle ganz genauen
mengenangaben bestehen wie immer unten
in der infobox und für unseren
zuckersirup brauchen wir wasser und
zucker natürlich und da gebe ich jetzt
gleich noch ein spritzer zitronensaft
rein und wenn ihr mögt es ist also
typisch arabisch jetzt orangenblüten
wasser nur einen kleinen schuss daher
kommt man noch mal so lange mit der
flasche aus weil so ein kleiner schuss
hat schon eine riesen wirkung
geschmacklich wie kann jetzt beschreiben
es fängt orientalisch also es ist so
orient pur und ich versuche das jetzt
genau zitronen wird dezentral rein und
dann las ich dass du 23 minuten köcheln
[Musik]
also das hat jetzt richtig an uns genagt
am war und mir und kamerafrau für für
die die es noch nicht wissen und wir
haben echte max wonach stück das sie
einmal probiert und sie sagt es schmeckt
sowie blumen riechen wie diese blumen
das ist nämlich das sind nämlich
orangenblüten hier auf der verpackung
also so könnt ihr euch das vorstellen
steht jetzt nicht nach orange weil sind
dennoch orangenblüten so haben wir das
auch geklärt wann ich doch fand ich
jetzt interessant und jetzt fangen wir
an mit der cheesecake masse das wird
einfach nur ganz schnell zusammengerückt
dafür nämlich doppel ram frischkäse
nimmt da einen warmen einerseits gibt es
nicht das habe ich in san sebastian
schlägt video da haben alle geschlossen
ich finde kein ohne salz ihr könnt aber
annehmen der salz abgeschmeckt und dann
nehme ich zum beispiel wenn es kein
fehler darf ja so und da gebe ich dann
in zwei eier mit ryan und eigentlich
werden wirklich nur alle zutaten verriet
ich habe jetzt hier noch ein bisschen
zucker aber in der extrakt speisestärke
für die bildung und ein bisschen sahne
[Musik]
richies cache masse ist fertig ich geb
dir jetzt noch ein bisschen
orangenblüten wasser mit rein aber das
müsst ihr nicht dass es jetzt nur
optional also wenn es gerne mit gibt es
gerne auch noch in die ski skate masse
und die brauchen wir jetzt erstmal nicht
die masse die kommt jetzt kurz zur seite
wenn das ist quasi unser unsere
zwischenschicht und damit ist schlecht
vorbereitet ist haben wir das einfach
schon mal gemacht jetzt geht es direkt
weiter mit unserem vorteil also ihr
braucht eine aus auf sichere backform
ihr könnt eine auflaufform nehmen ihr
könnt euch also ein bisschen an meine
maße halten schreibe ich euch in infobox
ich nehme ist meine eckige springform
denn ihr müsst euch vorstellen später
wenn der zucker sirup drauf kommt ist
jetzt so was zum beispiel also ein bug
ram wer jetzt nicht geeignet weil da
wird es alles raus fließen das wollen
wir nicht hier kann auch gerne was draus
schließen aber hier habt ihr quasi noch
so eine auffang rille und seid da auf
jeden fall auf der sicheren seite und
was wir auch benötigen wackler mit yoga
das ist ja oft extra für baklava findet
ihr eher so ein türkischen supermärkten
auch im kühlregal teilweise und der
trocknet sehr schnell aus daher habe ich
auf jeden fall schon ein küchentuch
parat und bedeckt es immer schön mit dem
tuch weil wirklich den furz trocken wenn
ihr das an der luft stehen hast also
hört da auf meine worte sind ärgert ihr
euch
[Musik]
die lüfterblätter habe ich jetzt
zugeschnitten das geht ja ganz easy
indem wir einfach den spring vom rand
auf den oft große blatt liegt und man
könnte einfach mit dem messer entlang
schneiden und ihr habt da auf jeden fall
seinen größten rest sage ich mal aber
den können wir auf jeden fall trotzdem
verwerten weil das jubeln wir einfach
dass zwischen das merkt man später gar
nicht und ich habe auch schon meine
mutter in der mikrowelle zu lassen bei
geringerer wattzahl und wenn ihr mögt
das ist dann halt dieses also es ist
sowieso ist ein kein traditions- rezept
wir vermischen ja den new york
cheesecake mit traditionellen baklava
aber wenn die milch gibt dort gerne noch
mutter die mit rein es ist auch immer
das geheimnis syrischen konditoreien und
bäckereien gewesen dann noch mal butter
geht dieses ganz spezielle mit in die
butter zurückzuweisen uhr das zu
verwenden bei wackler war und schmeckt
einfach gut wenn ihr das grab so wenig
darf macht dass wir nicht dann lasst es
einfach weg so und jetzt machen
erfolgende wie bei normalem mit
traditionellen baklava fangt ihr an die
butter mischung abwechselnd mit dem
luftfahrzeug hier in die form zu legen
zu auf dem boden gebe ich jetzt schon
mal so ein bisschen von der mutter
mischung und dann immer nur ein blatt
reinlegen mit dem pinsel einfach schön
benetzen und wenn ihr mir das manchmal
nach gefühl wird wenn ihr mögt zähne ich
jetzt einfach mal die blätter mit damit
ihr wisst wie viele schichten was
ungefähr sind und dann sage ich euch
gleich wie geschichten es war und wie
wir dann weiter vorgehen
[Musik]
haben wir eventuell eine strichliste
geführt während wir das ganze geschichte
haben ja haben wir extra für euch 25
blättert könnte 26 oder 24 aber nur das
in der richtlinie habt ich habe jetzt
auch mit butter abgeschlossen so und
jetzt kommt noch der ganz typischer
baklava eine nuss schicht dazu ihr könnt
wahlen müssten ihr könnt pistazien h
sind es keine was auch immer er möchte
die gesagt das gesamtgewicht ist dabei
wichtig und ich nehme jetzt hier eine
mischung aus pistazien und haselnuss
kernen und die werde ich jetzt hier
einfach nicht ganz fein schon so ein
bisschen größer beim mixen und dann
könnt ihr damit die masse so ein
bisschen ja damit sie nicht ganz so
trocken ist könnte da gleich auf jeden
fall vom zuckersirup schon ein bisschen
was dazu geben und dann kommt es erst
mal hier auf den fehler teig da drüber
kommt denn die cheesecake masse und
überlegt eigentlich könnte man mit ein
bisschen losglück masse muss ich weiß
noch nicht ob es ein sind vielleicht
versuche ich einfach und dann schließen
wir wieder mit dem rest philo teig ab
das sollte man auch so ungefähr 25
schichten seien
[Musik]
also ich hab jetzt abgeschlossen
natürlich mit viel teig und nochmal mit
butter und ich habe den ofen auch schon
vorgeheizt auf 180 grad ober und
unterhitze das ganze wird jetzt
goldbraun gebacken aber vorher das ist
wie beim normalen traditionellen baklava
müssen wir uns die stücke einschneiden
weil danach wird erstens ein bisschen
schwierig denn der viel teig wird super
knusprig und der der zucker sirup muss
ja auch seinen weg finden das ist man
besser wenn ihr das zuvor einschneidet
ich guck mal wie ich das mache ich
glaube ich noch so dreiecke wie beim
nussecken ihr könnt aber auch einfach
nur so linien einschneiden bis ganz nach
unten gern und direkt nach dem backen
wird das ganze mit zuckersirup
übergossen es darf dann auch ruhig noch
warm sein das ist kein problem sogar
sirup ist abgekühlt und dann müsst ihr
stark sein weil der nachlass ist
komplett auskühlen ihr seht mich dann
erst morgen wahrscheinlich wieder im
test ist aber dass jedes wert sein
[Musik]
hayward wir machen jetzt so kurz vor elf
uhr abends sind es das kann man sich
auch mal so ein back davos für so nicht
wir probleme hätten ich merke schon oben
richtig los bringt also ich würde schon
ein stück für zwei personen sagen da ist
es schon sehr groß war richtig knusprig
oben der kommt jetzt übrigens gut
durchziehen einer nacht im kühlschrank
wir brauchen mindestens wirklich viel
schon im kühlschrank dass dadurch 10
kann
[Musik]
frisch verkehrsminister dieser frische
parc du hast einfach so ein grundlos
amerikanisch mit orientteppichen
wirklich ist deswegen in der mitte
komplett amerikanisch was ich aber sagen
'ja ja
hast du das jedoch nicht irgendwann
vorher anrufen betraf ja dass die weko
also kraft dies ist matt in der mitte
ich diese frische kick und oben
knuspriger es ist nicht viel was ich mir
es ist nicht das ist genau richtig
geschmeckt diese de france ins
orientalische rufen deshalb ist ja
hochwasser das habe ich auch im video
gesagt glaube ich zumindest weil dieses
ordentlich bitten was es schmeckt
wirklich nach korea desto trotz kann man
auch ganz richtig beschreiben muss man
einfach mal probiert halt wirklich nur
ganz ganz wenig näher weil ich finds
richtig lecker aber ich bin eine portion
ist definitiv also haben wir werden
geboren teilen können krise gucken wir
häufig noch bei metallica also ist halt
echt mal was anderes
ja richtig richtig gute kombination mit
den missen aufgestellte gemacht hier ist
gut gemacht die halt machen leute leute
und machen richtig geiler kuchen viel
freude beim nachmachen und überhaupt
schon das nächste rezept also wir alle
zwei tage leute michael eckert
die komplexität einzelne kommentare
stieg im juni immer mehr also bis damals
[Musik]